peut-être pas
toujours y est toujours ouvert
bonjour ou bonsoir la planète
ici l'équipe de tan tan canada à
montréal nous sommes en direct heure de
montréal au canada on parle de l'heure
avancée ou l'heure normale de l'est
cette année rien n'y comprendre bien sûr
si vous êtes à l'étranger
c'est l'heure de montréal souhaite à
l'heure normale actuellement en mars
nous allons tomber à leur avance et il
va falloir courir rapidement automates à
nos humoristes de la semaine nous avons
à marivan humoristes ou humoriste ça
dépend des jours amari un vilain mot
tête mais c'est pas grave je suis la
crevette
lundi claude est avec nous madame simard
bonjour m est numéro 1 à la station
webmestre numéro vous êtes du genre
qu'est ce vous avez plusieurs choses à
faire alors que nous faisons cette
diffusion en direct de montréal pour le
bénéfice de la planète entière
aujourd'hui il ya un terme à cette
émission vous êtes au courant
il ne le sait peut-être pas mais on sait
qu'ils deviennent souvent les choses
donc on lui pose pas la question on se
retourne vers celles qui ne s'agit
qui ne s'est jamais rien mais vous vous
prêter au jeu c'est pour ça que je fais
le métier de journaliste aussi parce que
j'apprends tellement de choses tous les
jours
bon c'est fantastique vous n'avez pas
d'opinion préconçue vous êtes à chaque
jour c'est comme c'est nouveau pour vous
voilà voici nous vous présentons cette
vidéo vous n'avez que 15 secondes pour
déterminer pour découvrir le thème de
l'émission aujourd'hui vidé le numéro un
la presse la voix en même temps que vous
quel est le thème de l'émission
aujourd'hui les immigrants c'est en
partie ça continue et plus précis
d'ailleurs immigrants deux poissons oui
les travailleurs saisonniers saisonniers
et vous ne deviez pas parlé je les
devine et alors ça c'est une vidéo
promotionnelle du gouvernement du québec
pour informer ses travailleurs sur leurs
droits on va l'écouter je pense qu'il ya
du sombre qu'on peut c'est en espagnol
parce que ça s'adresse à des chaque
année des milliers de travailleurs venus
d'amérique latine comme vous sont
embauchés par les propriétaires de
hermes ou d'entreprise agricole au
québec des lois et des règlements
définissent les relations entre
employeurs et travailleurs
ces mêmes lois et règlements
s'appliquent aussi à vous comme
travailleurs étrangers temporaires
sinon peu importe la période de temps
que vous serez chez nous piqué ça cette
semaine à la commission des normes de
l'équité santé sécurité au travail
c'est sympathique d'ajuster le message à
la langue des gens qui viennent ici qui
assure g avant de présenter notre invité
mystère de la semaine d'une autre une
autre affaire il va falloir dévoilé
qu'ils sont ensemble j'ai une bonne
belle question
remuez vous le cerveau on a rebaptisé la
sphère commune et vous les méninges se
faisait un peu radio canada là c'est
remuer vous le cerveau qu'attendez vous
j'ajoute sans nom voici ça vaut pour 10%
l'examen final
et pour ça seulement 10% du tout point
important mais ça va l'être si vous
voulez gagner aujourd'hui notre prix de
participation voici la question
on vient de parler donc voir ce
travailleur ou deux le nombre de
travailleurs étrangers temporaires
représente quel pourcentage en ce moment
de toute la main d'oeuvre au canada en
ce moment même
quel pourcentage la main d'oeuvre de
travailleurs étrangers temporaires sur
tout le canada au canada ce canal
travailleurs travailleuses
quel pourcentage représente en ce moment
même 12% 7 pour ça je cligne des yeux
quand les réponses ne sont pas bannis 6%
alors joueur de poker c'est moi ok la
plus proche de ce qui était le plus
proche de la bonne réponse de pour ça
aux deux pour sens
alors là 10% vous avez de billet de
passage 10 pour s'accumuler parce que je
formalise les choses a d'autres choses à
vous présenter en primeur cette semaine
mais c'est un peu technique et je pense
qu'on a déjà les bras assez chargé les
2% ok j'ai vraiment exagéré alors partez
pas tomber dans le sensationnalisme
c'est non c'était peut-être même un peu
plus ya quelques années à peine sous les
consommateurs alors qu'il ya eu un
mouvement de populaire contre trop de
personnes dans l'étranger qui remplaçait
des travailleurs canadiens qui auraient
pu faire l'emploi sont lassants là il ya
eu donc un ressac politique là surtout
dans l'ouest canadien
alors deuxième question remis vous le
cerveau de huy deux questions d'affilée
au début de l'émission je vous dise et
c'est très chargé comme programme
aujourd'hui
alors voici la deuxième question
l'obtention d'un permis de travail pour
travailleurs étrangers temporaires
s'avère au final une porte d'entrée pour
l'obtention d'une résidence permanente
au canada
saviez-vous ça se répéter oui vous êtes
vous obtenez un permis de travailleurs
temporaires étrangers
oui très souvent ça vous ouvre la porte
très souvent très pour obtenir
éventuellement un statut devenir
permanent et statut de canadiens de pour
résider ici un jour d'accord c'est ton
d'entrée c'est comme le tricycle même ou
au permis de conduire éventuellement
bien sûr pour ça qu'il ya beaucoup de
mauvais conducteurs sur les routes
alors voici la question quel pourcentage
de travailleurs étrangers en ce moment 1
qui sont autour de 300 milles c'est
beaucoup ça qu'ils vont obtenir
éventuellement le droit de rester ici au
canada comme travailleur permanent qui
vont pouvoir gagner sans toi je voulais
oui sur ses traces en mille pourcentage
1 30% 22% 22%
moi je vous dis c'est le sel qui a
répondu 21% elle et elle est peut-être
tombé en plein dedans
alors c'est pas compliqué non seulement
c'est la bonne réponse 10% des notes
mais quand on tombe juste il faut
récompenser vous avez dit très souvent
et pourtant ce n'est que 21%
c'est quand même une porte d'entrée de
plus quand on y pense parce qu'ils se
familiarisent au pays
mais je pense que ça aurait été plus
basse est en augmentation parce que ce
n'était que 9% entre 95 et 99 ramener
ces gens là ils apprennent les rouages
ou peut-être que c'est plus clair au
gouvernement c'est la comprendre je ne
sais pas on va demander notre avis des
mystères dans quelques instants pour
présenter cet invité mystère je vous
présente cette histoire dans l'actualité
il ya quelques mois en fait en 2016 une
histoire que nous avons beaucoup suivi
ma radio canada international vidéo
numéro 2 où on voit des travailleurs n'a
du guatemala trois d'entre eux mais ils
étaient au nombre de quatorze qui entend
fonde voulaient les expulser du
gouvernement que je vous renvoie les
expulser parce qu'il n'avait pas dix et
ont le permis de travail
en fait ils disaient non on s'est fait
flouer on s'est fait arnaquer par une
compagnie qui nous a dit de travailler
at-elle entreprises mais on avait il
n'avait pas le permis on ne savait pas
quand même besoin d'un permis
je pars à pas je vais vite mais on les
voit qui arrivent ici pour se plaindre
dans 1 dans un jeu pensé au niveau des
autorités policières
ça se passe au québec il ya deux ans
grosse histoire
je ne sais pas comment ça s'est terminé
1 j'allais vous poser la question mais
voici oui
l'avocate qui les représentent et on
peut lire on peut écouter je pense que
non oui en tout cas on va attendre je
pense dans son instant un des personnes
qu'elle représentait porto convenait
c'est kevin parent par famille qui mène
un contrat reconquête en contrat d un
c'est quelque chose alors on va aller
voir comment ça s'est terminé ce soit ou
si ça se poursuit avec l'avocat qui
représentait non seulement ce groupe
mais qui connu au québec comme étant une
de celles qui défend les gens qui soient
avoir par notre système ou par par des
airs par des gens ou privé ici su mettre
ce jeune ramires bonjour madame la
mairesse
bonjour m soyons formelle d'accord merci
infiniment d'avoir pris un petit peu de
quelques minutes de votre temps je me
sens coupable parce que je sais que vous
les utilisez vos minutes pour faire des
choses qui sont assez extraordinaire
défendre des gens qui des fois ce
retrouvions impression n'avoir aucun
aucun droit comment s'est terminée cette
histoire il y en avait beaucoup à dire
je pense effectivement l'histoire mais
toujours pas terminée on est toujours en
processus nous nous sommes rendus à la
cour fédérale le 18 octobre 2017 et pour
des questions qui vont au delà de deux
mois et qui malheureusement on nous a
interdit d'en parler plus longuement
après s'être entretenu avec le juge en
chambre l'audience a été remise au 23 et
23 juin juste avant la saint jean donc
2018 18 m
donc ce qu'on ce qu'on débattait à la
cour fédérale s'était pas si vous avez
juste écouter un petit extrait mais bref
on en parle de 15 personnes qui sont
sorties à la lumière parce qu'en réalité
on parle d'une trentaine mais celui qui
sont sortis à la lumière et qui se sont
fait arrêter un en octobre 2016 se sont
fait arrêter parce que ils ont été
maltraités dans la chaleur premier
employeur qui les a fait venir au canada
et ce nouvel employeur leur propre état
d'une agence de placement leur fait
miroiter de meilleures conditions de
travail un salaire juste et respectée
selon le contrat puisque le premier
n'était pas respecté
des meilleures conditions d'habitation
et leur fille dit le roddick pour
changer le permis de travail
il fallait payer 4500 dollars enfin le
franchement pour le nouveau nouvel
employeur donc il est allé les chercher
il les a commencé à travailler pour des
nouvelles fermes et des nouveaux
endroits et le redis inquiétez vous pas
je vais vous avancer l'argent je suis
assez fin pour payer l'avocat à l'avance
et vous allez faire d'un overtime pour
me rembourser
et donc on parle il y en a partout
certains parmi eux qui travaillait aux
alentours de 140 heures par semaine à
rembourser le prêt des stands alors le
plus vite et qu'il ne leur restait dans
leur poche que 300 dollars nets par
semaine et finalement le permis de
travail ne s'est jamais effectuée donc
ni le consultant en immigration n'a rien
fait ni l'employeur a rien fait non plus
et lorsque les premières fermes se sont
plaints à l'immigration de la limite
comment est ce qu'on appelle c'est
l'exode massif de leurs employés à l'
agence des services frontaliers a fait
enquête et s'est rendu compte que il
travaillait pour cet employeur là et a
fait une arrestation massive de cette
journée l'oeil à la caisse qui ont été
arrêtés parce qu'il n'avait pas de
permis de travail pour travailler là où
ils étaient en train de travailler
mais ce qu'on est en train de débattre à
la coupe raisonnement au niveau de
l'immigration c'est que l'agent sans mal
agi l'agent salle avait tout la preuve
devant elle c'était une enquête
d'envergure qui a duré des mois
vidéosurveillance drones surveillant ce
pardon ils étaient surveillés dans les
champs de fraises avec des drones
il avait des photos prises de en train
de travailler de tous et si comme si
l'on victimiser les victimes au lieu de
les aider et leur ont dit non on va vous
des portes et vous avez travaillé
illégalement et le propriétaire de
l'entreprise et le consultant en
immigration
1 ils sont encore libres il ya aucun
chef d'accusation qui pèsent sur eux
mêmes s'ils enquête continue ya un qui
se passe
du moins 2 qu'est ce que je peux en
parler et de qu'est-ce qu'on
mais on m'informe aussi parce qu'on est
tenu à l'écart de toutes les enquêtes et
on voulait les embarquer tout de suite
le lendemain dans un avion equi où
est-ce qu'ils sont en ce moment aux
risques et la
heureusement on a des permis de travail
ouverts ils ont tous des emplois
différents
il y en a qui sont dans le domaine de la
construction il y en a qui sont dans le
domaine agricole
il y en a qui vont dans des manufactures
mais ils travaillent tous dans des
domaines différents
avec tout ce qui s'est passé justement
lorsqu'ils sont dans des fermes
ils sont pas obligés de parler la langue
mais lorsqu'on a des permis de travail
ouverts puis qu'on fait face au marché
du travail il faut apprendre la langue
donc la société civile s'est mobilisé
pour leur donner des cours de français
pour les intégrer dans la société pour
qu'il puisse aller chercher un travail
compétent dans n'importe quel secteur
commercial
il leur famille ou et la famille de ces
différentes personnes là ça c'est un
autre une autre bataille qu'on ne soit
en train de mener présentement parce que
le 18 octobre
toute cette saga aurait dû à être
élucidées mais ça n'est pas le cas et
malgré leur volonté leur séjour au
canada s'est prolongée jusqu'en juin
2018 donc ça va faire pour la plupart
2-1 2-1 qui n'ont pas pu voir leur
famille ils ne peuvent pas les
territoires canadiens parce que dès
qu'il mette un prix d'or l'entente aussi
longtemps qu'on règle pas la question de
l'interdiction de territoire ils ne
pourront pas revenir et je ne peux pas
demander parce que je ne peux pas mais
on n'acceptera pas des maîtres les visas
pour tous les membres de leur famille
alors ce qu'on en fait c'est une
pétition spéciale pour au moins faire
émettre un visa par par groupe familial
que ce soit lipouz où l'un des enfants
pour qu'ils viennent les visiter parce
que psychologiquement c'est très dur
pour eux mais j'ai pas encore de réponse
sur ça m a remis à un cela on sent que
là on sent on pense moi je pense que
c'est un cas extrême mais vous avez dit
dans une entrevue un moment donné à
radio canada que c'est un problème
systémique effectivement là j'ai eu un
problème
deux honduriens maintenant donc vous
allez bientôt entendre le nouveau
dossier
on a une vingtaine de travailleurs
hondurien dans une femme au québec qui
sont maltraités en ce moment et qui il y
en a quelques uns d'entre eux qui ont
décidé de sortir à la lumière mais
contrairement au wat et maltais qu'ils
sont avertis et au lieu de faire
confiance à n'importe quel employeur
ils ont décidé de nous contacter
personnellement pour avoir un avis
juridique de quoi femmes
donc en ce moment ils sont sans emploi
on est en train de demander un nouveau
permis de travail et ils vivent encore
une fois de la charité sont hébergés
dans des églises
mais la problématique c'est que les
livres terme
ils ont des sanctions la porte la
commission des normes de travail ok ils
ont une amende et la paix et ça s'arrête
là
le gouvernement ne ne le met pas en
place une structure pour justement
prévenir ces dommages là et prévenir que
si les employés la veille il déserté les
fermes pour lesquels ils sont au travail
et c'est important dire que le
gouvernement a un rôle à jouer dans ces
histoires puisque ce sont des employeurs
qui ont qui font des demandes pour des
travailleurs à travers un programme
fédéral donc au bout de la ligne celui
qui devrait être utilement responsable
de comment on traite ces gens là ça
devrait être le grand saut fédéral
devant un mécanisme d un des inspecteurs
ça doit être un peu plus rigoureux on
semble accepter ces 100 millions c'est
ici qu'il ya comme une je sais pas l'ons
le sait comme il n'ya pas de suivi y a
pas de suivi par exemple service avicole
le temps le dossier des travailleurs
guatémaltèques
on est présentement sur la table de
négociation quand on dit on
je ne représente pas mis mes clients
devant la commission ce sont d'autres
collègues le font mais je les suis je
les les épaules et je les suis un peu
partout dans leurs processus et ils sont
présentement sur la table de négociation
en ce moment pour recevoir un
dédommagement pour les dommages moraux
qu'ils ont subies sur la ferme mais
c'est immigration canada qui aimait les
permis de travail c pas cette entreprise
là pour ses employés là si on
capable d'émettre une liste noire ou du
moins de les faire vraiment changé on
émettrait plus les permis de travail
pour cette forme là mais ça continue
à chaque vague à chaque saison ils ont
encore cinquantaine d'employés ont
encore la limitation canada-uni permis
la commission des normes et mais des
amendes et ça n'arrête pas que l'on va
poursuivre ici la conversation avec
d'autres témoignages notamment d'autres
avocats des spécialistes une dernière
question oui j'aimerais savoir c'est la
situation des travailleurs temporaires
et et pire au québec qu'ailleurs au
canada où c'est un phénomène généralisé
au canada c'est un phénomène par
canadien à olemps fait dans d'autres
dossiers là des femmes en ontario les
fermes laitières c'est très
problématique
il ya des problèmes également un peu
plus dans l'ouest là les fermes bovines
c'est un problème canadien c'est pour ça
que le moins à la cour fédérale ils
veulent vraiment s'assurer de couvrir la
problématique est non seulement le
problème des travailleurs guatémaltèques
car si la question j'aurais pris la pose
et je mets peut-être gêné parce que
c'est un problème national
merci beaucoup m ramires thiago bonne
journée bonne journée
alors ces maîtres suzanne ramires
ensemble lancée sous peu un comme ça
c'est important surtout en apprenant
cette semaine qu'on était le deuxième
meilleur pays au monde une fois oui mais
finalement c'est un peu gênant de doser
la firme aecom c'est justement avant de
poursuivre plus loin d'autres enquêtes
parce qu'on fait une enquête aujourd'hui
on essaie de se mettre dans les pas de
ces travailleurs étrangers au sujet de
la popularité du canada voici une
question remuez vous l'aimez neige on va
le faire sans sourire c'est mais quand
même beaucoup de gens qui nous regardent
en dix ans et moins le canada j'aimerais
ça y allait y travailler
que ce soit de façon temporaire ou de
façon permanente un sondage qui était
finlande sur la liste des 100 pays voici
la question vous écoutez bien on était
sur la liste des 100 pays au monde où le
travailleur de 18 à 35 ans les minimes i
knew bhl de la planète souhaiterait le
plus aller s'établir pour mieux faire
progresser leur carrière oui à quelle
place situe donc le canada sur les seins
pays l'un les plus à ce qu'elle soit de
réponse
les gens vous en donne au moins 50 plus
de 50
on aime on fait partie des 50 premiers
vous êtes sûr d'avoir la bonne réponse
alors soyons plus précis parce que je
donne des coups de pieds il faut donner
le en 10e place en sixième place
très bien c'est dire est la septième
classe et combien vaut ce cette question
30% pour les gazaouis 90% by bonne
réponse c'est extra c'est énorme
deuxième place deuxièmement car cette
réputation après les états unis la
deuxième place soit au canada dans le
tas des sondages 31 minutes
quand je suis à mille milles parce qu'en
fait quand on se compare on se rassure
j'imagine parce qu'il doit y avoir pire
ailleurs oui oui bien sûr oui il ya du
travail à faire mais bon j'imagine qu'en
comparaison 18 % veulent aller aux
etats-unis et 12% choisir le canada
troisième pays c'est laura nos mairies
royaume uni 10 pour ça le premier pays
c'est les états unis oui parce que bon
le sait si vous gagner à la loterie ou
vous gagnez une façon d'aller travailler
à bob faire de l'argent venait riches
comme monsieur tromper devenir président
c'est le rêve américain
écoutez on voudrait parler de aller vers
la vidéo numéro 4 d'accord on va aller
plus loin plus rapide que nous avions
prévu de le faire pour vous parler la
responsabilité du gouvernement
on a fait un article là dessus sur la
responsabilité du gouvernement parce que
on a interdit une spécialiste voilà
l'article en question cela avoir
l'original vous allez sur la page de
tentes au canada cette semaine
donc là on vous montre l'image de détail
à quoi ça ressemble si on descend un peu
avant une entrevue avec une spécialiste
du travail du droit du travail à
l'université du québec à montréal à
boissy adam dahlia jésus elle dit
fecteau et à va nous dire pourquoi le
fédéral
devrait un peu plus responsable et
comment surtout oeuvre pour le compte
des employeurs canadiens donc ils
demandent qu'un employeur décide de sous
traiter en quelque sorte ou
d'augmentation de faire pour conduire
finalement le recrutement des
travailleurs bain à quelque part la
question qui se pose c'est quelle est la
responsabilité des employeurs canadiens
et québécois à l'égard du processus de
recrutement
donc c'est pour ça qu'à notre avis il
faut que l'état canadien prenne ses
responsabilités et comment mais dans le
cas des travailleurs guatémaltèques au
moins aussi que l' agence de recrutement
est souvent le c'est un peu technique
mais assez de rendre mon propos le tout
leur possible et souvent le monde à
terre des travailleurs auprès des
autorités auprès de l'ambassade
canadienne au guatemala donc comment ça
fonctionne pratiquement et que l' agence
de recrutement va être le mandataire du
travailleur auprès de l'ambassade
canadienne donc sur les documents
officiels traités par l'ambassade
canadienne se frôlent agence de
recrutement qui sera le mandataire du
travail art donc quittera
l'interlocuteur de l'ambassade
canadienne pour le compte du travail art
non content c'était un moment alors que
les autorités canadiennes pourraient
avoir un pouvoir un peu plus grands
d'observer et de questionner les
pratiques de ces agences devront donc au
départ avant même que commence le jeu
après quand ils sont arrivés au canada
le canada pourrait s'immiscer dans le
processus s'est enlisé nous qui sommes
au final responsable et on va suivre
d'affaires d'un peu plus près on aurait
peut-être des inspecteurs sur le terrain
il faut dire que non seulement il ya des
cas où ils se font exploiter lorsqu'ils
sont arrivés ici mais se font exploiter
avant de partir et c'est ça que j'ai
oublié de vous raconter tout cela c'est
que on leur dit si tu veux venir au
canada tu vas payer 5000 $ et tu veux
pas tu as pas l'argent pour avoir cet
emploi au canada a battu peut
hypothéquer ta petite demeure et onu on
va être responsable de l'hypothèque pour
toi et ça c'est donc j'appellerai sans
raquette en utilisant un bon jeu pc
français de match que c'est vilain et
c'est ce qui se passe très souvent par
le dal parler du cas des gones le
guatémaltèque sacile on l'a vu récemment
au niveau 2
ce pop unique jeu c'est la réalité
aujourd'hui là c'est la réalité de ce
beau pays deuxième plus beau pays au
mans aujourd'hui hier et avant-hier ça
se passait aussi comme ça il ya dix ans
il y avait un temps là c'est pas nouveau
peut-être que c'était pire c'est ça mais
ce qui est lamentable c'est de savoir
que ça se produit encore en 2018 là et
on a beau en parler voyez ces reportages
ne date pas d'hier et pourtant ça
continue maintenant quand ils sont ici
il ya certains aspects qu'on n'a pas
évoqué ensemble c'est que ils sont
souvent vulnérables aux accidents parce
que vous montez sur un petit tracteur a
pour couper l'herbe lier la première
fois de ma vie à 7 janvier dû voir
c'était dangereux de le voir aller oui
l'été dernier ainsi travailleurs qui a
perdu la vie au québec
ces travailleurs de 50 55 ans lieu-dit
coupent l'herbe il n'avait jamais
utilisé ça et se retrouver dans une
pente puis il a tourné avec la machine
voilà un exemple ça dont on leur donne
de l'équipement ils sont pas familiers
et aucune assurance qu'une sécurité
d'emploi donc sa famille se retrouve
avec rien puis comme il parle pas la
langue
on ne peut pas dire la tension là quand
tu voir descendre la colline un plus de
15% degrés c'est dangereux
j'en ai des collines chez moi je fais
attention c'est sûr on est tous passés à
côté de danger dans la vie en dix ans
sait comment ça fonctionne mais voici
donc une spécialiste aussi du monde du
travail
merci du québec à montréal une autre
spécialiste interviewé récemment par
radio canada international d'original
sur la page de tomtom canada cette
semaine on va écouter sans centre c'est
la numéro 3 on est près des emplois pour
lesquels les risques sont prévues la
plupart du temps ce sont des emplois
pénibles des emplois moins répétitif et
et des emplois pour lesquels ils ont peu
ou pas d'encadrement et particulièrement
dans les agences de la carte personnelle
les travailleurs sont affectés dans des
entreprises clientes
mais ils ne sont pas nécessairement
superviser et encadrer
lors d'une session la taz est dans
l'instant le petit nez leur travail
et comme ce sont des inquiète des plages
de l'affectation à l'autre
qui sont constamment le bilan mobilité
les entreprises clientes considère que
c'est pas leurs employés puisque c'est
la relance et de toute façon si des
travailleurs qui sont que de passage
donc on ne se soucie peu ou pas de leur
sécurité
les emplois de manutention les antoine
nettoyage
le spar de nettoyage nettoyage grande
machinerie avec des solvants pour
dégraisser la mécanique sa voix disant
toi dans des entreprises par exemple
d'abattage donc des gens qui travaillent
avec des graisses animales qui travaille
à rennes avec des appareils entre un
chat donc c'est pas des emplois lot
intéressant et qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que ces gens-là lot fois les
réflexes de prudence de quelqu'un qu'il
faut toujours avoir eu un emploi de
mannequin
voilà on va revenir à ce que la
fragilité de ces de ces travailleurs là
où quand ce sont dans notre milieu de
travail tellement vulnérable je voulais
vous proposer notre question tam-tam
canada cette semaine qui est un peu lié
à tout ça le thème de l'émission vous
rappelez geste que j'ai des dissidents
au début d'émission dans la tête d
ailleurs étrangers temporaires au canada
c'est le site de l'émission d'accord
ayant un lien avec notre question
tam-tam canada on va la découvrir
ensemble je demandais à leonardo de
nuire la question sur votre cv était
celui d si votre cv
non mais j'avais pas les micros et que
faire si votre cv et sur votre cv était
celui de youssef ollier vous les mêmes
chances aussi maintenant en fait c'est
qu'ils manquent le début de la phrase si
le nom inscrit sur votre cv
ainsi les noms tels son cv c'est le lieu
s'est pliée vous les mêmes chances au
canada dé décrocher un emploi
[Musique]
le candidat qui s'appelle stéphane jobin
passe à travers ce qu est un jeune mois
0 sur banal et xt et fabien mathématique
non plus si je sais que c'était l'espoir
n'est ce pas ouais c'est pas bon à spa
non je t'ai excellent bon écouter alors
la question on a bien compris si votre
nom sur le cv c'était youssef plutôt que
joseph ou quelles seraient vos chances à
ce que c'est les même si je devais
chercher un emploi ici au canada
on a déjà eu des travaux de recherche
sous gestion
il ya eu de tout des gens qui ont fait
les mêmes cv avec du nom différent ou
envoyez là même un triplé s'il introduit
ses amis à contacter la personne qui
avait les noms et pas être un génie
alors oui il ya un impact intéressant
fait référence un sondage a fait une
enquête faite en 2012 au québec et puis
35 % de différence entre sion si on
savait que vous étiez youssef et non un
joseph dans l'aval le nombre de rappels
de la part de l'employeur
alors voilà je pense qu'on ne peut
répondre à la question mais anne-marie
vont vous avez une opinion non j'ai pas
une opinion une constatation
tout dépend en fait qui vous engage et
les choses évoluent on le voit à radio
canada il ya un service de la diversité
donc à radio canada c'est sûrement plus
facile qu'ailleurs mais mettons que je
prends le milieu des médias
quand vous regardez ce qui se passe dans
le monde du privé dans les médias des
youssef des mohamed
des tout ce que vous voulez y en a pas
beaucoup ils sont extrêmement solides et
la morale partout à travers le québec
quand je sais pas si ça se passe
différemment ailleurs au canada mais au
québec vous regarder la télévision
comment l asie tantôt c'est vraiment
indépendant de l'employeur je connais
des cas où l'employeur québécois il ya
employé
en fait il y avait quatre postes bien
employé 3par sont issus de l'immigration
puis un québécois et une de ses passes
ayadi a demandé à son employeur après
qui a travaillé plus d'un mois il ya
entre un contact avec lui a dit écoutez
je me le savoir pourquoi vous avez
choisi les trois migrants il est trois
passants qui sont des québécois biasi
écoute mon travail c'est pas un travail
constant alors normalement les personnes
qui ont vécu beaucoup de temps ici au
québec ils sont très spécialisés dans
des choses particulier puis s'ils font
pas son travail puis je demande à faire
notre choix par exemple et des mois à
faire l'inventaire et de nous non
je suis et spécialiste en ça je n'ai pas
fermé mais les immigrants dont les
passants qui sont venus après au québec
ils ont pris à travailler passant près
tout faire faire son travail
ils ont beau être des spécialistes parce
qu'il ya certains médecins d'autres qui
sont avocats mais ils sont prêts est
chauffeur de taxi donc ils sont tous
fait que alors les métiers avait choisi
un menu des trois québécois s'il choisit
trois immigrants pasquet il savait que
son travail était pas tous les jours la
même qualité de travail à la il aimait
beaucoup plus à voir des gens qui
étaient prêts à travailler dans d'autres
choses dans son milieu
c'est un très beau très beau sujet
néracaise je pense il ya une enquête
fédérale là on a connu des résultats
cette semaine vous avez lu d'article
j'ai du temps article damas c'était
surprendre par rapport à ce que les eaux
apportées comme
ils ont fait quoi au fédéral il envoyait
ils ont l'air si l'on fait comme un
projet pilote
et puis on évalué à savoir si les gens
qui avaient des noms sur leur cv qui
était moins si on veut typique louise
canada et puis les résultats de leur
enquête il semble dire qu'il n'ya aucune
différence aucune suis autant de gens
qui sont employés dans la fonction
publique fédérale
avec des noms de souche canadienne que
des noms de gentil qu'il y avait
seulement 1 % de différence entre si on
connaît le nom du candidat ou si on
connaît pas le nom du candidat s'il a
été masquée sauf que et c'est ce qu'il
fallait lire dans les banques est en
bout de ligne c'est des des mains des
petits caractères il avait informé les
17 ministères et départements qui
faisaient l'objet de cette enquête
alors je comprends dernier pendant 3
pendant dix mois tout le monde c'est
beaucoup mieux ici qu'ailleurs dans le
monde
dans mon pays en argentine par exemple
d'annoncer vo mais sexe on met les noms
on met la famille si on a des enfants au
port et on met beaucoup des données aux
ménages puisent ces données là sont
vraiment de donner que les gens
utilisent pour définir vraiment prendre
la décision des prêts ont pas la passion
qui est oui qu'ils ont fait ici on met
jamais je regarde mes vieux cv puis je
mettais tout ces informations là oui
mais maintenant encore là ça dépend
peut-être de l'employeur c'est comme
chercher un appartement ça il ya des
informations à ne pas donner et pourtant
on nous les exige
une autre contestation contester ce
qu'on confrontation combler nos cibles
constatations aux contestations
concernant une constatation de votre
part au lieu d'une opinion qui très bien
ça vient du mont espagnol constatations
c'est la même chose c'est pas ça que je
l'avais ficultés est l'animateur la
semaine prochaine parce que c'est ça le
jeu à l'espagnole ou et avec les sous
titres donc un jour on va le faire
bon alors écoutez on a des réponses
d'abord jacqueline brunel je pense que
oui qui a pas de différence entre
youssef et joseph dans les chances
d'obtenir un emploi à partir d'un cv au
québec je pense que oui part au canada
nous ne sommes pas racistes et nous
avons l'esprit ouvert
personne qui croit donc que nous sommes
le meilleur pays au monde
j'imagine et puis monsieur steve stevens
qui habite à new york donc aux états
unis on va voir ce qu'il pense on va
demander
[Musique]
il est certain que le fait d'avoir un
nom qui n'est pas dit s'ils n'aident pas
toujours malgré tout les vagues
d'immigration il ya toujours un groupe
de nouveaux arrivants qui est pénalisé
lors des concours de sélection parce que
leurs noms ne sont pas familiers aux
oreilles des décideurs
je pense que l'erreur statistique le
proof
mais voilà le problème justement on n'a
pas suffisamment de données dans
quelques critiques
je pense qu'on devrait en parler plus et
dénoncé la faire en faisant et on
commande en plus d' enquêtes
statistiques
je pense que les autorités manquent de
courage et ont peur de poser les bonnes
questions
sans ces questions on ne pourra jamais
apporter de véritables réponses aux
injustices systématique autour de nous
merci de nous avoir posé la question
c'est gentil merci d'avoir répondu mais
ce que je peux vous dire un petit truc
quand j'ai eu ma fille j'ai longuement
réfléchi aux prénoms j'allais lui donner
pour savoir pour en fait pour l'assurer
des meilleures chances dans la vie
parce que son papa vient d'un autre pays
et je savais que si je lui donnais un
prénom qui sonnait comme le pays d'où il
est originaire ça lui donnerait moins de
chance dans la vie
c'est fou hein alors lui donner un
prénom neutre qui peut passer partout
c'est quoi le prénom luna luna luna
espagnols espagnols
elle aimait son papa n'a pas d'origine
espagnole les usa c'est quand même
relativement neutre ça passe partout
j'espère en tout cas alors luna au
guatemala écoutez dernière vous êtes
prêts pour la quatrième et dernière
question de notre jeu remy vous le
cerveau d'accord il y en a quatre
cette semaine quatre questions
normalement il y en a 3 mais on change
de règlement la semaine prochaine vous
amener mon une affaire électronique
parce qu'il va changer complètement la
perspective sur ce jeu si j'ose pas le
faire parce que c'est vraiment vous
allez voir ça fait un peu hollywood là
si on échoue ce que ça veut dire qu'on
peut plus venir à l'om non non non non
j'aime savoir des cards en studio ayant
des élèves mais qu'entre ces magnifiques
fait des belles émissions
écoutez on est prêts pour la dernière
vous avez quels sont les pourcentages la
forme 30 30%
c'est vrai c'est 10 515 ouais je suis
bon en mathématiques
et vous bon j'en ai dit c'est tout le
monde a quelque chose
moi j'ai zéro bon alors on y va pour la
donne en question tout près de 17
millions de canadiens sur une population
de 36 millions occupe un emploi au
canada temps partiel temps très occupé
trop occupés on sait la même chose dont
17 millions là dessus il y en a combien
enfin il ya combien de postes
présentement qui reste à combler ils ont
trouve pas les candidats taux de chômage
est autour des 6% 6 5% qu'un éventuel
mans on trouve pas les gens qualifiés
on va être obligés de se tourner vers
l'étranger y'a pas de canadiens ici il
ya des postes à combler combien y at-il
de postes à combler en ce moment même
aucun
il ya 17 millions doit canadiens qui ont
déjà un emploi qui gérait 2 millions aya
papa oui 95000 j'ose pas vous regarder
dans les yeux quand vous dites 2
millions m cinq cent cinquante trois
mille secrets 895 1553 553 et vous c'est
895 8,5 alors elle va bien la course
alors comme il y en a un des trois qui
pendant la course
allez-y vous allez droit encore une
autre au cas d'échec mentionné nous
devons encore
moi je reste autour de 5cm 625000 c'est
pas bon à 500 et c'était pas bon je vous
demande d'avoir la vôtre c'est moins
alors 260 10270 1145 145000 ça c'est dit
c'est votre compte de banque saint nom
ont tiré des chiffres comme ça nulle
part moi je les tire de je veux dire la
bonne réponse et vous allez levez la
main si vous vous reconnaissez hockey
361 1700 c'est vous alors 50% vous
ajoutez 5 60% faut parier faire mieux la
prochaine fois 3,75 au troisième
trimestre c'est à le nombre de postes à
combler au canada on trouve pas les
candidats et pourtant
ouais il ya quand même un certain taux
de chômage au canada
5 je pense que oui c'est ça c'est la
situation la semaine prochaine on
parlera pas de chômage vous en parler
d'autre chose
je n'ai un message du 6 et joël on
aurait quand même qui ai dit c'est le
nom de l'immigration est un et en direct
à lui nous voient en direct des doigts
là il est 17h la douce 12 puis beaumont
pour lui ces bons choix
ben oui parce que le soleil ils disent
probablement ni gauche et à 5 heures le
soir là bas est ce moi j'habitais au
gabon pendant quelques années pas loin
de chez vous j'ai dû visiter à son beau
pays douala cameroun union douala
séparés mais pas encore alors écoutez
merci pour cette semaine joves laissés
sur des images d'accord alors pendant
qu'on fait nos âges vous pouvez vous
tourner la caméra numéro 38 et dire au
revoir à tout le monde voilà
pendant qu'on se quitte nous allons
présenter la dernière de nos vidéos
programmés pour la journée aujourd'hui
on a ça nous a coûté cher donc fois que
vous utilisez
et puis c'est au sujet d'un documentaire
primé au canada sur le sort des
travailleurs autonomes de travailleurs
temporaires étrangers et voyez s'est
traduit en anglais il ya une version
française à lire sur notre site web
tam tam canada je vais avoir la suite de
cette histoire pour continuer à vous
plonger dans les pas de youssef
au canada la semaine prochaine
anne-marie vont marie claude simard et
léo gimeno donc à la semaine prochaine